this kind of radical racial policy it's
not just affecting our nation's most
prestigious universities
it's going down into elementary schools
christopher ruffa who covers
these sorts of issues specifically
critical race theory at city journal is
doing great stuff
he just got a scoop that buffalo public
schools are now are now claiming quote
all white people
perpetuate systemic racism they are now
forcing kindergarteners there
according to this report to watch a
video of dead black children
warning them about racist police and
state-sanctioned violence
uh he says that he's got the
whistleblower documents here
this is the sort of thing being this is
the narrative being voiced it
on students now it doesn't just start
when you're
a law school student it starts when
you're a little kid
and by the way this does actually tie
into the kind of ron paul
vision of liberty and libertarianism or
whatever
we have we have to make sense of our
liberty we do that through liberal
education and this has been true for
millennia
liberal education exists to teach us to
tamp down our passions and our base
desires
and to pursue our our higher ordered
appetites and you know pursue our
our virtues and practice the virtues and
make sense
of our own freedom this is why the left
always goes after the kids that's why
they go after education
broadly and they go after education
really hard and why they go after
younger and younger kids because
if you can get to a kid when he's five
years old you have a much greater
opportunity to shape his mind
this is why maybe some of you when you
were growing up your parents said hey
don't watch the simpsons or at least
don't watch this don't watch that you
can't watch that movie that's why
there's rating systems in movies
because we know that children absorb
much more than adults do the content
that is around them and it helps shape
the way that they think
it's why we're much more concerned about
keeping
kids away from obscene material than we
are about keeping adults away because
when you're an adult you're a little
more formed
it's going to have less of an effect on
you well the left
is now not just going after the adults
or even the teenagers they're all the
way going after the kids with these sort
of perverse
policies not just throwing the kids in
cages which joe biden's doing but but
things that are
actually much much more dangerous if you
enjoyed that break from disinformation
historical revision and screaming about
the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button so
that you never miss another video
[Music]
[Music]
you